The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, let's start.
So, we've moved onto the
two-dimensional xy model.
This is a system
where, let's say
on each side of a square lattice
you put a unit vector that
has two components
and hence, can
be described by an angle theta.
So basically, at each side,
you have an angle theta
for that side.
And there is a tendency for a
neighboring spins to be aligned
and the partition
function can be
written as a sum over
all configurations, which
is equivalent to integrating
over all of these angles.
And the weight that wants
to make the two neighboring
spins to be parallel
to each other.
So we have a sum over
nearest neighbors.
And the dot product of
the two spins amounts
to looking at the cosine
of theta i minus theta j.
And so, we have this
factor over here.
Now, if we go to the
limit where k is large,
then the cosine will tend
to keep the angles close
to each other.
And we are tempted to expand
this around the configurations
where everybody's parallel.
Let's call that nk
by the factor of 2.
And then, expanding with the
cosine to the next order,
you may want to replace
this-- let's call this k0--
and have a factor of k,
which is proportional
to k0 after some
lattice spacing.
And integral of gradient
of theta squared.
So basically, the difference
between the angles
in the continuum version,
I want to replace
with the term that tries to
make the gradient to be fixed.
OK.
Now the reason I put these
quotes around the gradient
is something that we
noticed last time, which
is that in principal,
theta is defined up
to a multiple of 2 pi.
So that if I were to take
a circuit along the lattice
that comes back to itself.
And all along, this circuit
integrate this gradient
of theta, so basically, gradient
of theta would be a vector.
I integrated along a circuit.
And by the time I have come back
and close the circuit to where
I started, the answer
may not come back to 0.
It may be any integer
multiple of 2 pi.
All right.
So how do we account for this?
The way we account
for this is that we
note that this gradient of data
I can decompose into two parts.
One, where I just
write it as a gradient
of some regular function.
And the characteristic
of gradient
is that once you go over a
closed loop and you integrate,
you essentially are
evaluating this field
phi at the beginning
and the end.
And for any regular
single valued phi,
this would come back to zero.
And to take care of
this fact the result
does not have to come
to zero if I integrate
this gradient of theta, I
introduce another field, u,
that takes care of these
topological defects.
OK?
So that, really, I have to
include both configurations
in order to correctly capture
the original model that
had these angles.
OK, so what can this u be?
We already looked at what
u is for the case of one
topological defect.
And the idea here
was that maybe I
had a configuration where
around a particular center,
let's say all of the
spins were flowing out,
or some other such
configuration such
that when I go over a large
distance r from this center,
and integrate this field u,
just like I did over there,
the answer is going to
be, let's say, 2 pi n.
So there's this u.
And I integrated
along this circle.
And the answer is
going to be 2 pi n.
Well, clearly, the
magnitude of u times
2 pi r, which is the
radius of the circle
is going to be 2 pi times
some integer-- could
be plus, minus 1, plus minus 2.
And so, the magnitude
of u is n over r.
The direction of u is orthogonal
to the direction of r.
And how can I show that?
Well, one way I
can show that is I
can say that it is z
hat crossed with r hat,
there z hat is the vector
that comes out of the plane.
And r hat is the unit
vector in this direction.
u is clearly orthogonal to r.
The direction of the gradient of
this angle is orthogonal to r.
It is in the plane so
it's orthogonal to this.
And this I can also
write as z hat 3
crossed with the gradient of
log of r, with some cut-off.
Because the gradient of
log of r will give me,
essentially, 1 over R in
the direction of r hat.
And this is like
the potential that I
would have for a charge
in two dimensions,
except that I have
rotated it by somewhat.
And this I can also write
as minus the curl of z hat
log r over a with a factor of n.
And essentially,
what you can see
is that the gradient of
data for a field that
has this topological
defect has a part
can be written as a
potential gradient of some y,
and a part that can be
written as curl to keep track
of these vortices, if you like.
If you were to think of
this gradient of data
like the flow field that you
would have in two dimensions.
It has a potential part.
And it has a part that is due to
curvatures and vortices, which
is what we have over here.
OK.
So this is, however, only
for one topological defect.
What happens if I have
many such defects?
What I can do is, rather
than having just one of them,
I could have another topological
defect here, another one here,
another one there.
There should be a
combination of these things.
And what I can do in order
to get the corresponding u
is to superimpose solutions
that correspond to single ones.
As you can see that
this is very much
like the potential
that I would have
for a charge at the
origin, and then
taking the derivative
to create the field.
And you know that as long
as things are linear,
and there aren't
too many of them,
you can superimpose solutions
for different charges.
You could just add up
the electric fields.
So what I'm claiming
is that I can write u
as minus n curl of z hat, times
some potential u of r, where
psi of r is essentially the
generalization of this log.
I can write it as a sum over
all topological defects.
And I will have the n of that
topological defect times log
of r minus ri
divided by a, where
ri are the locations of these.
So there could be a vortex
here at r1 with charge n1,
and other topological defect
here at r2 with charge n2,
and so forth.
And I can construct a
potential that basically looks
at the log of r minus ri
for each individual one,
and then do this.
OK?
I will sometimes write this in
a slightly different fashion.
Recall that we had the
Coulomb potential, which
was related to log by just
a factor of 1 over 2 pi.
So the correct version of
defining the Coulomb potential
is this.
So this I can write as
the Coulomb potential,
provided that I
multiply the 2 pi ni.
And I sometimes
will call that qi.
So essentially, qi
is 2 pi and i is
the charge of the
topological defect.
It can be plus or minus 2 pi.
And then, the potential
is constructed
by constructing superposition
of those charges divided
or multiplied with
appropriate Coulomb potential.
OK?
All right.
So I can construct a cost for
creating a configuration now.
Previously, I had
this integral gradient
of theta squared
in the continuum.
And my gradient of
theta squared has now
a part that is the gradient
of a regular, well-behaved
potential, and a part
that is this field
u, which is minus-- oops.
Then I don't need
the ni's because I
put the ni as part of the psi.
Curl of z hat psi of r.
So phi is a regular function.
Psi with curl will give
me the contribution
of the topological
defect involves
both the charges
and the positions
of these topological defects.
OK?
And this whole thing has
to be squared, of course.
This is my gradient squared.
And if I expand this, I
will have three terms.
I have a gradient
of this 5 squared.
I have a term, which is minus
2 gradient of phi dot producted
with curl of z hat psi.
And I have a term that is
curl of z hat psi squared.
OK?
Again, if you think
of this as vector,
this is a vector
whose components
are the xy and the
y phi, whereas this
is a vector whose
components are, let's say,
dy psi minus dx psi.
Because of the curl operation--
the x and y components-- one
of them gets a minus sign.
Maybe I got the minus
wrong, but it's essentially
that structure.
Now you can see that if I were
to do the integration here,
there is a dx psi, dy psi.
I can do that integration
by parts and have,
let's say phi dx dy psi.
And then, I can do the same
integration by parts here.
And I will have phi
minus dx dy psi.
So if I do integration by
part, this will disappear.
Another way of seeing
that is that the gradient
will act on the curl.
And the gradient of the
curl of a vector is 0,
or otherwise, the curl
will act on the gradient
with [INAUDIBLE].
So basically, this term
does not contribute.
And the contribution of
this part and the part
from topological defects are
decoupled from each other.
So there's essentially
the Gaussian type of stuff
that we calculated
before is here.
On top of that,
there is this part
that is due to these
topological defects.
Again, this vector
is this squared.
You can see that
if I square it, I
will get dy psi squared
plus dx psi squared.
So to all intents and
purposes, this thing
is the same thing as a
gradient of psi squared.
Essentially, gradient
of psi and curl of psi
are the same vector, just
rotated by 90 degrees.
Integrating the square of
one over the whole space
is the same as integrating
the square of the other.
OK?
So now, let's calculate this
contribution and what it is.
Integral d2 x gradient of
psi squared with K over 2
out front-- actually
you already know that.
Because psi we see
is the potential
due to a bunch of charges.
So this is essentially
the electric field
due to this
combination of charges
integrated over
the entire space.
It's the electrostatic image.
But let's go through
that step by step.
Let's do the
integration by parts.
So this becomes minus k over 2.
Integral d2 x psi the
gradient acting on this
will give me Laplacian of psi.
Of course, whenever I
do integration by parts,
I have to worry
about boundary terms.
And essentially, if
you think of what
you will be seeing
at the boundary, far,
far away from there all of
these charges are, let's say.
Essentially, you will
see the electric field
due to the combination
of all of those charges.
So for a single one, I will
have a large electric field
that will go as 1 over r.
And we saw that integrating
that will give me the log.
So that was not
particularly nice.
So similarly, what
these boundary terms
would amount to would
give you some kind
of a logarithmic energy that
depends on the next charge
that you have enclosed.
And you can get rid of it
by setting the next charge
to be zero.
So essentially,
any configuration
in which the sum total of our
topological charges is non-zero
will get a huge energy cost
as we go to large distances
from the self-energy,
if you like,
of creating this huge monopole.
So we are going to
use this condition
and focus only on
configurations that
are charged topological
charge neutral.
OK.
Now our psi is what
I have over here.
It is sum over i qi.
This Coulomb
interaction-- r minus ri.
And therefore, Laplacian
of psi is essentially
taking the Laplacian
of this expression
is the sum over j qu.
Laplacian of this is
the delta function.
So basically, that
was the condition
for the Coulomb potential.
Or alternatively, you take
2 derivative of the log,
and you will generate
the delta function.
OK?
So, what you see is that
you generate the following.
You will get a minus k over 2
sum over pairs i and j, qi, qj.
And then I have the
integral over x or r--
they're basically
the same thing.
Maybe I should have
written this as x.
And the delta function
insures that x
is set to be the other i.
So I will get the
Coulomb interaction
between ri minus rj.
So basically, what you have is
that these topological defects
that are characterized by these
integers n, or by the charges
2 pi n, have exactly
this logarithmic Coulomb
interaction.
in two dimensions.
And as I said, this
thing is none other
than the electrostatic energy.
The electrostatic energy
you can write either
as an integral of the
electric field squared.
Or you can write
as the interaction
among the charges that give
rise to that electric field.
OK?
So, what I can do is I
can write this as follows.
First of all, I can maybe
re-cast it in terms of the n's.
So I will have 2 pi ni, 2 pi nj.
So I will get minus
4pi squared k.
There's a factor of one-half.
But this is a sum over i
and j-- so every pair is now
counted twice.
So I get rid of that
factor of one-half
by essentially counting
each pair only once.
So I have the
Coulomb interaction
between ri and rj, which
is this 1 over 2 pi
log of ri minus rj
with some cut-off.
And then, there's the term that
corresponds to i equals 2j.
So I will have a minus, let's
say, 4pi squared k sum over i.
And I forgot here
to put n, i, and j.
I will have ni squared.
The Coulomb interaction at zero.
ri equals [INAUDIBLE].
Now clearly, this expression
does not make sense.
What it is trying to
tell me is that there
is a cost to creating one of
these topological charges.
And all of this theory--
again, in order to make sense,
we should remember to put
some kind of a short distance
cut-off a.
All right?
And basically, replacing this
original discrete lattice
with a continuum will
only work as long as
I keep in mind that I cannot
regard things at the level
of lattice spacing, and replace
it by that formula, as we saw,
for example, here.
If I want to draw a
topological defect,
I would need right at the
center to do something
like this-- where replacing
the cosines with the gradient
squared kind of
doesn't make sense.
So basically, what
this theory is
telling me is that once you
get to a very small distance,
you have to keep
track of the existence
of some underlying lattice
and the corresponding things.
And what's really
this is describing
for you is the core
energy of creating
a defect that has object ni.
OK.
What do I mean by that
is that over here, I
can calculate what the partition
function is for one defect.
This we already did
last time around.
And for that, I can
integrate out this energy
that I have for the distortions.
It's an integral of
n over r squared.
And this integration
gave me this factor of e
to the minus pi k log of r over
a-- actually, that was 2 pi k.
Actually, let's do
this correctly once.
I should have done it
earlier, and I forgot.
So you have one defect.
And we saw that for one defect,
the field at the distance r
has n over r in magnitude.
And then, the net energy cost
for one of these defects--
if I say that I believe
this formula starting
from a distance a is the
k over 2 integral from a.
Let's say all the way up
to the size of my system.
I have 2 pi r dr from
a shell at radius r
magnitude of this u squared.
So I have n squared
over r squared.
But then, I have to worry
about all of the actual things
that I have off the distance a.
So on top of this,
there is a core energy
for creating this object that
certainly explicitly depends on
where I sit this parameter a.
OK?
This part is easy.
It simply gives
me pi km squared.
And then I have
the integral of 1
over r, which gives
me log of L over a.
So if I want to imagine what
the partition function of this
is-- one defect in
a system of size L--
I would say that z of one defect
is Boltzmann weight responding
to creating this entity.
So I have e to the minus pi
k m squared log of L over a.
And then I have the core energy
that corresponds to this.
And then, as we discussed,
I can place this anywhere
in the system if I'm calculating
the partition function.
So there's an integration
over the position
of this that is implicit.
And so, that's going
to give me the square
of the size of my system,
except that I am unsure as
to where I have placed
things up to this cut-off a.
So really, the
number of distinct
positions that I have scales
like L over a squared.
So the whole thing we
can see scales like L
over a 2 minus pi km squared.
And then, there is this
factor of e to the minus
this core energy
evaluated at the distance
a that I will call y.
Because again, in
some sense, there's
some arbitrariness
in where I choose a.
So this y would be a function of
a, if we depend on that choice.
But the most important
thing is that if I
have a huge system, whether or
not this partition function,
as a function of the size of
the system, goes to infinity
or goes to 0 is controlled by
this exponent 2 minus pi k.
Let's say we focus on the
simplest of topological defects
corresponding to n
equal 2 minus plus 1.
You expect that there is some
potentially critical value
of k, which is 2 over pi,
that distinguishes the two
types of behavior.
OK?
But this picture is nice,
but certainly incomplete.
Because who said that there's
any legitimacy in calculating
the partition function
that corresponds
to just a single
topological defect.
If I integrate over all the
configurations of my angle
field, I should really
be doing something
that is analogous to this
and calculating a partition
function that corresponds
to many defects.
And actually what I calculated
over here was in some sense
the configuration of
spins given that there
is a topological defects
that has the lowest energy.
Once I start with this
configuration-- let's
say, with everybody
radiating out--
I can start to distort
them a little bit which
amounts to adding this
gradient of phi to that.
So really, the
partition function
that I want to calculate and
wrote down at the beginning--
if I want to
calculate correctly,
I have to include both
these fluctuations
and these fluctuations
corresponding
to an arbitrary set of
these topological defects.
And what we see is that
actually, the partition
functions and the energy
costs of the two components
really separate out.
And what we are
trying to calculate
is the contribution that is
due to the topological defects.
And what we see is
that once I tell you
where the topological
defects are located,
the partition function for them
has an energy component that
is this Coulomb interaction
among the defect.
But there is a
part that really is
a remnant of this
core energy that we
were calculating before.
So when I was sort of
following my nose here,
I had forgotten a little
bit about the short distance
cut-off.
And then, when I
encountered this C of zero,
it told me that I have
to think about the limit
when two things come
close to each other.
And I know that that
limit is constrained
by my original lattice,
and more importantly,
by the place where
I am willing to do
self-averaging and replace
this sum with a gradient.
OK, so basically, this is
the explanation of this term.
So the only thing that we
have established so far
is that this partition
function that I wrote down
at the beginning gets
decomposed into a part
that we have calculated before,
which was the Gaussian term,
and is caused, really, the
contribution due to spin waves.
So this is when we just consider
these [INAUDIBLE] modes,
we said that essentially
you can have an energy
cost that is the
gradient squared.
So this is the part that
corresponds to integral d phi
into the minus k over 2 integral
d2 x gradient of phi squared,
where phi is a well-behaved,
ordinary function.
And what we find is that the
actual partition function also
has the contribution from
the topological defects.
And that I will indicate by ZQ.
And Q stands for Coulomb gas.
Because this partition
function Z sub Q
is like I'm trying to calculate
this system of degrees
of freedom that are
characterized by charges n that
can be anywhere in this
two-dimensional space.
And the interaction between
them is governed by the Coulomb
interaction in two dimensions.
So to calculate this,
I have to sum over
all configuration of charges.
The number of these charges
could be zero, could be two,
could be four, could be
six, could be any number.
But I say even
numbers because I want
to maintain the
constraint of neutrality.
Sum over ni should be zero.
So I want to do that
constrained sum.
So I only want to look at
neutral configurations.
Once I have
specified-- let's say
that I have eight charges--
four plus and four minus-- well,
there is a term that is
going to come from here
and I kind of said that the
exponential of this term I'm
going to call y.
So I have essentially
y raised to the power
of the number of charges.
Let's call this sum
over i ni squared.
And I'm actually just
going to constrain ni
to be minus plus 1.
I'm going to only look
at these primary charges.
So the sum over i
and i squared is just
the total number of
charges irrespective
of whether they
are plus or minus.
It basically is replacing this.
And then, I have
to integrate over
the positions of these charges.
Let's call this total number n.
So I have to
integrate i1 2n d2 xi
the position of
where this charge is
and then interaction which
is exponential of minus
4phi squared k sum
over i less than j.
And i and j the Coulomb
interaction between location
let's say xi and xj.
Actually, I want to also
emphasize that throughout,
I have this cut-off.
So when I was
integrating over one,
I said that the number
of positions that I had
was not L squared, but L
over a squared to make it
dimensionless.
I will similarly make these
interactions dimensioned
as I divide by a squared.
And so basically, this is
the more interesting thing
that we want to calculate.
Also, again, remember I wrote
this a squared down here,
also to emphasize that
within this expression,
the minimal separation
that I'm going
to allow between any pair of
charges is off the order of a.
I have integrated out or moved
into some continuum description
any configuration in which
the topological charges are
less than distance a.
OK?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Essentially,
when we were
during [INAUDIBLE] it
was canonical potential,
[INAUDIBLE], canonical ensemble.
And this is more like
grand canonical ensemble?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So, as far as the original
two-dimensional xy model
is concerned, I'm calculating
a canonical partition function
for this spin or angle
degrees of freedom.
And I find that that
integration over spin angle
degrees of freedom
can be decomposed
into a Gaussian part and a part
that as you correctly point out
corresponds to a grand
canonical system of charges.
So the number of
charges that are
going to appear in
the system I have not
specified whether it is
determined implicitly
by how strong these
parameter was.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
of canonical potential?
PROFESSOR: y plays the
role of E to the beta mu.
The quantity that
in 8333 we were
writing as z-- E to
the beta mu small z.
OK?
So, we thought we were
solving the xy model.
We ended up, indeed, with
this grand canonical system,
which is currently
parametrized by two things.
One is this k, which is this
strength of the potential.
The other is this y.
Of course, since this
system originally
came from an xy model that
went only one parameter,
I expect this y to
also be related to k.
But just as an expression,
we can certainly
regard it as a system
that is parametrized
by two things-- the k and the y.
For the case of
the xy model, there
will be some additional
constraint between the two.
But more generally, we can look
at this system with its two
parameters.
And essentially, we will try
to make an expansion in y.
You'll say that,
OK, presumable, I
know what is going to happen
when y is very, very small.
Because then, in the system I
will create only a few charges.
If I create many
charges, I'm going
to penalize by more
and more factors of y.
So maybe through leading
order, the system
would be free of charge.
And then, there
would be a few pairs
that would appear
here and there.
In fact, there should be
a small density of them,
even no matter how
small I make y.
There will be a
very small density
of these things
that will appear.
And presumably, these
things will always
appear close to each other.
So I will have lots and
lots of these pairs-- well,
not lots and lots
of these pairs--
a density of them that is
controlled by how big y is.
And as I make y larger-- so
this is y becoming larger-- then
presumably, I will generate
more and more of these pairs.
And once I have more
and more of these pairs,
they could, in principle,
get into each other's way.
And when they get
into each other's way,
then it's not clear who
is paired with whom.
And at some point, I
should trade my picture
of having a gas of
pairs of these objects
to a plasma of charges,
plus and minus,
that are moving
all over the place.
So as I tune this parameter
y, I expect my system
to go from a low density phase
of atoms of plus-minus bound
to each other to a high
density phase where
I have a plasma of
plus and minuses
moving all over the place.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So, y is related
to the core energy.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And core energy is
defined through [INAUDIBLE]
direction at zero separation--
PROFESSOR: Well, no.
Because the Coulomb
description is only
valid large separations.
When I get to short distances,
who knows what's going on?
So there is some underlying
microscopic picture
that determines what
the core energy is.
Very roughly, yes,
you would expect
it to have a form that
is of e to the minus k
with some coefficient
that comes from adding
all of those interactions here.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Just based
on the sign convention,
you're saying if you
increase or decrease y,
that it will go
from a low density--
PROFESSOR: OK, so y is the
exponential of something.
y equals to zero means I will
not create any of these things.
y approaching 1-- I will
create a lot of them.
There's no cost at
y equals to one.
There's no core energy.
I can create them as I want.
AUDIENCE: So this would be
like y equals minus epsilon c.
Is that right?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Didn't I have that?
You see in the exponential
it is with the minus.
OK.
But in any case, that
is the expectation.
Right?
So I expect that
when I calculate,
I create one of these defects.
There is an energy cost
which is mostly from outside.
And then, there's an
additional piece on the inside.
So the exponential of
that additional piece
would be a number
that is less than 1.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I mean, the original model
has some particular form.
And actually, the interactions
of the original model, I
can make more complicated.
I can add the full spin
interaction, for example.
It doesn't affect the
overall form much,
just modifies what
an effective k is,
and what the core
energy is independent.
OK?
All right.
But the key point is that
this system potentially
has a phase transition as you
change the parameter of y.
And another way of
looking at this transition
is that what is happening
here in different languages,
you can either call it
insulator or a dielectric.
But what is happening here
in different languages,
you can either call, say,
a metal or, as I said,
maybe a plasma.
The point is that here
you have free charges.
Here you have bound
pairs of charges.
And they respond
differently to, let's say,
an external
electromagnetic field.
So once we have this picture,
let's kind of expand our view.
Forget about the xy model.
Think of a system of charges.
And notice that in
this low-density phase,
it behaves like a
dielectric in the sense
that there are no free charges.
And here, there will be
lots of mobile charges.
And it behaves like a metal.
What do I mean by that?
Well, here, if I,
let's say, bring
in an external electric field.
Or maybe if I put a huge
charge, what is going to happen
is that opposite
charges will accumulate.
Or there will be, essentially,
opposite charges for the field.
So that once you
go inside, the fact
that you have an external
electric field or a charge
is completely screen.
You won't see it.
Whereas here, what
is going to happen
is that if you put
in an electric field,
it will penetrate
into the system
although it will be
weakened a little bit
by the re-orientation
of these charges.
Now, if you put a plus charge,
the effect of that plus charge
would be felt throughout,
although weakened a little bit.
Because again, some of these
dipoles will re-orient in that.
OK?
So, this low-density
phase we can actually
try to parametrize in terms of
a weakening of the interactions
through a dielectric
constant epsilon.
And so, what I'm going
to try to calculate
for you is to imagine that I'm
in the limit of low density
or small y and calculate
what the weakening is, what
the dielectric function
is, perturbatively in y.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: If you were talking
about the real electric charges
and the way to act
on that [INAUDIBLE]
real electric field or charge.
But if we are talking about
topological charges, what
would be kind of
conjugate force to that?
PROFESSOR: OK.
It's not going to be easy.
I have to do
something about say,
re-orienting all of the spins
on the boundaries, et cetera.
So let's forget about that.
The point is that
mathematically, the problem
is reduced to this system.
And I can much more
easily do the mathematics
if I change my perspective
and think about this picture.
OK?
And that's the thing you have
to do in theoretical physics.
You basically take
advantage of mappings
of one model to
another model in order
to refine your intuition
using some other picture.
So that's what we
are going to do.
So completely different picture
from the original spin models--
imagine that you have indeed
a box of this material.
And this box of material
has, because you're wise,
more some combination of these
plus and minus charges in it.
And then, what I do is
that I bring externally
a uniform electric
field in this direction.
And I expect that once
inside the material,
the electric field will be
reduced to a smaller value
that I will call E prime because
of the dielectric function.
Now, if you ever calculated
dielectric functions,
that's exactly what
I'm going to do now.
It's a simple process.
What you do, for
example, is you do
the analog of Gauss' theorem.
Let's imagine that we draw
a circuit such as this
that is partly on the inside,
and partly on the outside.
So I can calculate what the
flux of the electric field
is through this circuit, the
analog of the Gaussian pillbox.
And so, what I have is
that what is going on
is E. If I call this
distance to be L,
the flux integrated
through the entire thing
is E minus E prime times f.
So this is the integral of
the divergence of the electric
field .
And by Gauss' theorem, this has
to be charge enclosed inside.
OK.
Now, why should there
be any charge enclosed
inside when you have a
bunch of plus and minuses.
I mean, there will
be some pluses
and minuses out here
as I have indicated.
There will be some pluses
and minuses that are inside.
But the net of
these would be zero.
So the only place that
you get a net charge
is those dipoles that
happen to be sitting right
at the boundary.
And then, I have to count
how many of them are inside.
And some of them will
have the plus inside.
have the minus inside.
And then, I have to
calculate the net.
The thing is that my dipoles
do not have a fixed size.
The size of these
plus/minus molecules r
can be variable itself.
OK?
So there will be some that are
tightly bound to each other.
There may be some that are
further apart, et cetera.
So let's look at pairs
that are at the distance r
and ask how many of them hit
this boundary so that one
of them would be inside,
one of them will be outside.
OK?
So, that number has
to be proportional
to essentially this area.
What is that area?
On one side, it is L. On
the other side, it is R.
But if the dipole is
oriented at an angle theta,
it is, in fact r cosine theta.
OK?
So that's the number.
Now, what I will have here
would be the charge 2 pi.
So this is qi.
Actually, it could
be plus or minus.
The reason that there's
going to be more
plus as opposed to minus
is because the dipole
gets oriented by
the electric field.
So I will have a term here that
is E to the E prime times q
ir-- so that's 2 pi r.
So this is qr again,
times cosine of theta.
So we can see that,
depending on cosine of theta
being larger than
pi or less than pi,
this number will be
positive or negative.
And that's going to be
modified by this number also.
And of course, the strength
of this whole thing
is set by this parameter k.
And also how likely it
is for me to have created
a dipole of size r is controlled
by precisely this factor.
A dipole is something
that has two cores.
So it is something that will
appear at order of y squared.
And there is the
energy, according
to this formula, of
separating two things.
And so you can see that
essentially, n of r--
maybe I will write it
separately over here--
is y squared times E to
the minus 4pi squared k.
And from here, I have
log of r divided by a.
And then there's
a factor of 2 pi
because the Coulomb
potential is this.
So, this is going
to be y squared
a over r to the power of 2 pi k.
The further you try to
separate these things, the more
cost you have to pay.
OK.
So if you were
trying to calculate
the contribution of,
say, polarizable atoms
or dipoles to the dielectric
function of a solid,
you would be doing exactly
this same calculation.
The only difference is that
the size of your dipole
would be set by the
size of your molecule
and ultimately, related
to its polarizability.
And rather than having
this Coulomb interaction,
you would have some
dissociation energy or something
else, or the density itself
would come over here.
So, the only final
step is that I
have to regard my system
having a composition
of these things of
different sizes.
So I have to do an integral
over r, as well as orientation.
So I have to do an
integral over E theta.
Of course, the
integration will go
from a through essentially, the
size of the system or infinity.
I forgot one other
thing, which is
that when I'm calculating how
many places I can put this,
again, I have been
calculating things
per unit area of a squared.
So I would have to divide
all of these places
where r and L appear by
corresponding factors of a.
OK?
So, the last step
of the calculation
is you expand this quantity.
It is 1.
For small values of
the electric field,
it is 2 pi r E prime cosine
of theta k plus higher order
terms.
And then, you can do the
various integrations.
First of all, 1 the
integration against 1
will disappear because
you are integrating
over all values of
cosine of theta.
Integral of cosine of
theta gives you zero.
Essentially, it says that if
there was no electric field,
there was no reason for there
to be an additional net charge
on one side or the other.
So the first term
that will be non-zero
is the average of cosine
theta squared, which
will give you a
factor of one-half.
And so, what you will get is
that E minus E prime times
L is-- well, there's
going to be a factor of L.
The integral of the
theta cosine of theta
squared-- the integral of
cosine of theta squared
is going to give you 2 pi,
which is the integration times
one-half.
So this is the integral
the theta cosine
square theta will give you this.
So we did this.
We have two factors of y.
y is our expansion parameter.
We are at a low density limit.
We've calculated things
assuming that essentially, I
have to look at one
value of these diplodes.
In principal, I can imagine that
there will be multiple dipoles.
And you can see that ultimately,
therefore, potentially, I
have order of y to the fourth
that I haven't calculated.
OK, so we got rid
of the y squared.
We have a factor of E prime
on the expansion here.
This factor is bothering me
a little bit-- let me check.
No, that's correct.
OK, so I have the factor of k.
I have a factor of 2 pi here
that came from the charge.
I have another 2 pi here--
so I have 4pi squared.
I think I got everything
except the integration
over a to infinity dr.
There is this r dr, which
is from the two
dimensional integration.
There was another r
here, and another r here.
So this becomes r to the three.
From here, I have minus 2 pi k.
And then, I have the
corresponding factors
of a to the power
of 2 pi k minus 4.
OK.
So you can see that
the L's cancel.
And what I get is
that E-- once I
take the E prime
to the other side--
becomes E prime 1 plus I have
4pi cubed k y squared-- again,
y squared is my small
expansion parameter.
And then, I have the integral
from a to infinity, the r, r
to the power of
3 minus 2 pi k, a
to the power of 2 pi k minus
4, and then order of y squared,
y to the fourth.
OK.
So basically, you see that
the internal electric field
is smaller than the
external electric field
by this factor, which takes
into account the re-orientation
of the dipoles in order to
screen the electric field.
And it is proportional
in some sense
to the density of these dipoles.
And the twist is that
the dipoles that we have
can have a range
of sizes that we
have to integrate [INAUDIBLE].
So typically, you would write
E prime to the E over epsilon.
And so this is the
inverse of your epsilon.
And essentially, this is
a reduction in everything
that has to do with electric
interactions because
of the screening
of other things.
I can write it in the
following fashion.
I can say that there is
an effective k-- that's
called k effective-- which is
different from the original k
that I have.
It is reduced by a
factor of epsilon.
So we were worried when we
were doing the nonlinear sigma
model that for any
[INAUDIBLE], we
saw that the parameter k was
not getting modified because
of the interactions among the
spin modes, and that's correct.
But really, at
high temperatures,
it should disappear.
We saw that the
correlations had to go away
from power law form
to exponential form.
And so, we needed some
mechanism for reducing
the coupling constant.
And what we find here is
that this topological defects
and their screening provide
the right mechanism.
So the effective
k that I have is
going to be reduced
from the original k
by the inverse of this.
Since I'm doing
an expansion in y,
it is simply minus
4pi cubed ky squared,
integral a to infinity dr,
r to the 3 minus 2 pi k,
a to the 2 pi k minus 4, plus
order or y to the fourteenth.
OK.
Now actually, in the lecture
notes that I have given you,
I calculate this formula in
an entirely different way.
What I do is I assume that I
have two topological defects--
so there I sort of maintain the
picture of topological defect.
And their interaction
between them
is this logarithmic interaction
that has coefficient k.
But then, we say that this
[INAUDIBLE] interaction
is modified because I can create
pairs of topological defect,
such as this, that
will partially
screen the interaction.
And in the notes,
we calculate what
the effect of those
pairs at lowest order
is on their interaction
that you have between them.
And you find that the
effect is to modify
the coefficient of
the logarithm, which
is k, to a reduced k.
And that reduced k is
given exactly by this form.
So the same thing you
can get different ways.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What if
k is too small--
PROFESSOR: A-ha.
Good.
Because I framed the
entire thing as if I'm
doing a preservation
theory for you
in y being a small parameter.
OK?
But now, we see
that no matter how
small y is, if k is in
fact less than 2 over pi--
so this has dimensions of
r to the 4 minus 2 pi k.
So if k is less than 2 over pi--
which incidentally is something
that we saw earlier--
if k is less than that,
this integral diverges.
So I thought I was
controlling my expansion
by making y arbitrarily
small, but what
we see is that no matter
how small I make y,
if k becomes too small,
the perturbation acuity
blows up on me.
So this is yet another example
of a singular perturbation
theory, which is what we
had encountered when we were
doing the Landau-Ginzburg model.
We thought that our co-efficient
of phi to the fourth u
was a small parameter.
You are making an expansion
naively in powers of u.
And then we found an
expression in which
the coeffecient-- the thing
that was multiplying u
at the critical point
was blowing up on us.
And so the perturbation
theory inherently
became singular,
despite your thinking
that you had a small parameter.
So we are going to
use the same trick
that we used for the case of
the Landau-Ginzburg model--
this is deal with
singular perturbations
by renormalization group.
So what we see is that
the origin of the problem
is the divergence that
we get over here when
we try to integrate
all the way to infinity
or the size of the system.
So what we do instead is
we said, OK, let's not
integrate all the way.
Let's replace the
short distance cut-off
that we had with something
that is larger-- ba--
and rather than integrating all
of a to infinity, we integrate
only over short distance
fluctuations between a and ba.
This is our usual [INAUDIBLE].
So what we therefore get
is that the k effective is
k 1 minus 4pi q ky
squared integral
from a to ba br r to the 3 minus
2 pi k a to the 2 pi k minus 4.
And then, I have to still
deal with 4pi cubed ky
squared, integral
from ba infinity dr
r to the 3 minus 2 pi k,
a to the 2 pi k minus 4,
plus order of y to the fourth.
OK?
All right.
So, you can see that the
effect of integrating this much
is to modify the decoupling
to a new value which
depends on b, which is just
k minus 4pi cubed k squared
y squared, a to ba br r
to the 3 minus 2 pi k.
a to the 2 pi k minus 4.
OK?
And then, I can rewrite
the expression for k
effective to be this k tilde.
And then, whatever is
left, which is 4pi cubed k
squared y squared
integral ba to infinity dr
r to the 3 minus 2 pi k, a to
the 2 pi k minus 4, order of y
to the fourth.
You see that k has been shifted
through this transformation
by an amount that is
order of y squared.
So at order of y squared
in this new expression,
I can replace all the k's
that are carrying with k tilde
and it would still be
correct for this order.
Now I compare this expression
and the original expression
that I had.
And I see that they are pretty
much the same expression,
except that in this
one, the cut-off is ba.
So I do step two of origin.
I define my R prime to be dr
so that my new cut-off will
be back to a.
So then, this
whole thing becomes
k effective is k tilde
minus 4pi cubed k
tilde squared y squared.
Because of the transformation
that I did over here,
I will get a factor of b to
the 4 minus 2 pi k tilde,
integral from a' to infinity--
the r prime-- r prime to the 3
minus 2 pi k tilde, a to
the 2 pi k tilde, minus 4
plus order of y
to the fourteenth.
So we see that the same
effective interaction
can be obtained from
two theories that
have exactly the same cut-off,
a, except that in one case,
I had k and y.
In the new case, I have this
tilde or k prime at scale b.
And I have to
replace where I had
y with y with this
additional factor.
So the two theories
are equivalent provided
that I say that the new
interaction at scale b
is the old interaction minus
4pi cubed k squared y squared.
This integral is
easy to perform.
It is just the power law.
It is b to the fourth
minus 2 pi k minus 1.
And then, I have 4 minus 2 pi
k order of y to the fourth.
And my y prime is
y-- from here I
see b to the power
of 2 minus pi k.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: This k squared?
AUDIENCE: Oh, I see.
Sorry.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So, our theory is described
in terms of two parameters--
this y and this k.
or let's say, it's
inverse-- k inverse,
which is more like temperature.
And what we will
show next time is
that these recursion
relations, when I draw it here,
will give me two
types of behavior.
One set of behavior
that parameterizes
the low temperature dilute
limit that corresponds
to flows in which y
goes through zero.
So that when you look at the
system at larger and larger
lens scales, essentially it
becomes less and less depleted
of these excitations.
So, once you have integrated
the very essentially,
you don't see any excitations.
And then there's
another phase, which
as you do this removal of
short distance fluctuations.
You tend to flow to
high temperatures
and large densities.
And so, that corresponds
to this kind of face.
Now the beauty of
this whole thing
is that these recursion
relations are exact and allow
us to exactly determine
the behavior of these space
transition in two dimensions.
And that's actually one
of the other triumphs
of renormalization
group is to elucidate
exactly the critical
behavior of this transition,
as we will discuss next time.